Transcription: eric vautier
Relecteur: Claire Ghyselen
« Elle m’a piqué.
Je me suis débattu,
mais je n’ai rien pu faire.
Je me rappelle cette douleur sournoise,
presque vexante, comme un flash.
Un éclair.
Et ce petit dard là qui était resté planté
dans mon bras, qui m’a gratté,
qui m’a gêné et qui a provoqué
une inflammation. »
Pour la plupart d’entre nous,
une piqûre est la seule relation
que nous ayons avec les abeilles,
un point de contact, de rencontre,
entre nos deux espèces.
Le monde des abeilles est
presqu’invisible à nos yeux.
Pourtant, elles vivent
à proximité de l’Homme.
En silence.
Elles font le lien
entre les fleurs et nous.
Les scientifiques disent de l’abeille
à miel qu’elle est un insecte eusocial,
c’est-à-dire que
d’une multitude d’abeilles,
donc d’une multitude d’organismes
biologiques à part entière,
elle est capable de former
des super organismes
qui auront à leur tour
leurs propres propriétés biologiques.
Ces super organismes
s’appellent colonies d’abeilles
et ce sont ces colonies que nous sommes
capables d’élever dans une ruche.
Pour ce super organisme,
une abeille est l’équivalent
d’une cellule chez un mammifère.
Un petit fragment de vie
à l’existence tout éphémère.
Et symétrie de l’évolution,
ce super organisme est en de nombreux
points comparable à un mammifère.
Prenons quelques exemples.
Il est capable de maintenir en son sein
une température de 35°C
pour assurer le développement optimal des
larves et nymphes des futures abeilles.
Cette température « corporelle »
est assurée
par le cumul des actions individualisées
de plusieurs centaines d’abeilles.
En effet, une abeille fait fonctionner
les muscles de ses ailes
sans que ses ailes ne bougent.
Elle les débraie en quelque sorte,
pour ne pas s’envoler dans la ruche.
Ce faisant, elle fait monter
sa propre température
et diffuse cette chaleur
au couvain environnant.
Inversement, les abeilles sont capables
de rafraîchir l’air ambiant
en brumisant des gouttelettes d’eau
tout en battant des ailes,
générant ainsi un flux d'air frais.
Pas mal, n’est-ce pas ?
Une colonie d’abeilles à miel
est capable de collecter, stocker,
transformer de la nourriture pour qu’elle
reste consommable pendant des années.
Cette capacité fait d’elle
une espèce hyper compétitrice
comparée à beaucoup d’autres
espèces d’abeilles moins connues.
Il y en a des milliers à travers le monde,
une quarantaine en Nouvelle-Calédonie.
Ainsi, l’abeille à miel concentre par
quatre les sucres contenus dans le nectar
quand elle le transforme en miel.
Elle sait convertir le pollen des fleurs
par un processus de lactofermentation
oui, de lactofermentation.
Quand même !
Ce procédé lui permet d’assurer
la conservation des protéines.
Enfin,
elle produit la fameuse gelée royale,
qui n’est rien d’autre qu’une sorte
de lait infantile ultra-énergétique
produit par les abeilles pour maximiser
la vitesse de développement des larves.
Elle permet aussi d’assurer
la longévité de la reine
qui vit 40 fois plus longtemps
que les ouvrières.
Enfin, les abeilles sécrètent de la cire.
La cire, c’est un matériau organique
dont les propriétés mécaniques varient
avec les changements de température.
On connaît tous les alvéoles hexagonales
et on imagine que les abeilles
sont de fines architectes.
Pourtant, au départ,
quand elles les fabriquent,
les alvéoles sont cylindriques.
Elles utilisent leur propre
corps comme gabarit.
Rien de fou à ça.
Ce n’est pas vraiment l’abeille
qui décide de la forme en hexagone,
c’est plutôt la matière elle-même
qui le décide.
Oui, c’est à cause des tensions
entre les parois des cellules
qu’elles prennent cette forme.
Bon, cela dit, là où l’abeille
regagne en génie,
c’est qu’elle semble savoir
que cette méthode
lui permet une occupation optimale
de l’espace avec un minimum de cire,
et comme elle chauffe
volontairement la cire,
la rendant plus malléable,
les alvéoles prennent
leur forme définitive.
Les rayons de cire sont le support
de tous les organes de la colonie,
véritable colonne vertébrale
autour de laquelle s’agence le nid à
couvain et les réserves de nourriture.
Les rayons de cire servent également
de système de communication
en transmettant
les très légères vibrations
que les abeilles émettent à sa surface.
Imaginez,
vous, monsieur, que vous tapiez sur votre
accoudoir un message codé en morse -
c’est pas mal, ça ! -
et que vous, madame là-haut, vous
soyez capable d’en sentir les vibrations
et d'en comprendre immédiatement
la signification.
Et que vous tous, là, vous autres,
vous ayez participé à la fabrication
des rangées de sièges
en sécrétant de la cire
tout droit sortie de votre abdomen.
Eh oui, ça se passe
comme ça dans une ruche.
Et, truc incroyable,
afin que ce système de communication reste
efficace quand les températures s’élèvent,
les abeilles incorporent
un petit bourrelet de propolis
à la surface de chacune des alvéoles.
Ce matériau est plus rigide que la cire
et transmet mieux les vibrations.
C’est dingue !
Avec les ruches à cadre mobile,
celles que nous utilisons aujourd’hui,
les abeilles tissent leurs rayons
dans les cadres,
ces cadres que nous pouvons
manipuler, déplacer, échanger,
et qui nous permettent au final d’observer
l’animal par tranches successives.
C’est une sorte d’échographie, certes,
mais c’est surtout
une éventration du super organisme.
Et heureusement qu’il la tolère,
sans quoi l’apiculture moderne
ne serait pas possible.
Piqûre.
Ce petit dard qui était resté planté
dans mon bras est une merveille.
Si on le regarde de près,
on voit qu’il est composé
d’un aiguillon au centre,
de deux crochets anti-retour permettant
de le sécuriser dans notre peau
et d’assurer la lente contraction
de la poche à venin.
À votre avis,
quel est l’intérêt pour une abeille
en plein butinage de vous piquer ?
Elle meurt là, sur votre bras,
sans avoir la chance d’alerter
ses camarades du danger.
À votre avis,
quel est l’intérêt pour l’espèce
que l’un de ses membres, cette abeille,
meure au loin sur votre bras ?
Dans ce cas précis, il n'y en a aucun.
Lorsque l’abeille pique un autre insecte,
son dard ne lui arrache pas l’abdomen,
elle ne meurt pas.
Alors ?
Pourquoi une telle différence
de traitement ?
Est-ce car, malgré tout, l’abeille
ne s’est pas encore adaptée
à piquer le cuir mou et épais
des mammifères sans mourir ?
Ou que peut-être la dose
de venin nécessaire
pour venir à bout d’une si grosse bestiole
est telle qu’elle nécessite le sacrifice ?
Pourquoi mourir si bêtement ?
C'est son talon d'Achille.
Il faut bien qu’elle ait des défauts,
elle qui est si parfaite
dans nos imaginaires.
Rassurez-vous.
Pour venir à bout d’un être humain,
sauf allergie particulière,
il faut environ 1000 piqûres simultanées.
Et paradoxe,
la principale vertu du venin d’abeille
est d’être anti-inflammatoire.
Bon, c’est très mignon, mais entre nous,
après une trentaine de piqûres dans
une seule journée de travail aux ruches,
je sens que cela me fatigue
et parfois ça me tape sur le système.
Une colonie d’abeilles à miel,
pour se multiplier,
réalise une sorte de division cellulaire.
C’est une image, car en réalité,
cela n’a rien à voir.
Cette division s’appelle l’essaimage :
de un, elle devient deux.
La moitié partent avec l’ancienne reine
pour former une nouvelle
colonie viable à son tour.
Lors de l’essaimage, le choix
du nouvel emplacement est crucial
car il permettra à la nouvelle
colonie de survivre.
Imaginez-vous à la recherche
du meilleur emplacement
pour assurer la sécurité de votre famille.
Accès, isolation,
hauteur, humidité, ensoleillement,
protection, proximité d’eau.
Ce choix repose sur un processus
absolument démocratique
où les abeilles éclaireuses
évaluent chaque site
et décident ensemble
d’en retenir un en particulier.
L’intelligence décentralisée
d’une colonie d’abeilles
lui permet de connaître avec précision la
carte dynamique de l’environnement floral
sur une surface de 1000 hectares
autour de la ruche.
Cette capacité lui permet
d’assurer la mobilisation
immédiate de butineuses
dans une zone où une floraison
devient plus importante.
Imaginez le niveau de complexité
d’une telle connaissance
où chaque petit bosquet,
petit morceau de forêt, de savane,
est parfaitement connu et identifié
sans avoir recours
à aucun appareil électronique.
Une abeille pèse moins de 0,1 gramme.
Une belle colonie de 50 000 individus
pèse donc cinq kilos.
Dans ces cinq kilos de matière,
le cumul des cerveaux de toutes
les abeilles tient dans 50 millilitres
et comporte environ
48 milliards de neurones,
soit la moitié moins de mes
propres neurones d’être humain.
Certes, ils ne sont pas du tout
agencés de la même manière.
Dans ce super organisme, il n’y a pas de
poste de commandement opérationnel
compilant et digérant la totalité
des informations revenant du terrain.
La reine n'est pas
une despote omnisciente.
Son rôle principal est de pondre
et d’assurer la cohésion de la colonie
en émettant des phéromones
qui confirment sa présence.
D’ailleurs, il y a encore deux siècles,
les hommes ne savaient pas
que c’était la reine qui pondait,
alors cet individu à l’abdomen
proéminent était appelé le roi.
Logique.
Il était unique.
Il était le chef.
Il était forcément le roi.
Je vous laisse imaginer le choc que
ce fut pour les hommes de l’époque
de comprendre que le roi pondait,
qu’il était donc une reine.
Et il leur a fallu accepter que
la société des abeilles soit matriarcale
et repose quasi uniquement
sur le travail des castes féminines.
D’ailleurs, si nous imaginions
que cette salle soit une ruche,
il y aurait parmi nous
300 abeilles affairées à la tâche,
une reine qui occuperait
à elle seule dix sièges,
et seulement une vingtaine d’individus
de sexe masculin, les bras croisés,
en attente de leur petit et unique moment.
(Rires)
(Applaudissements)
Entre les abeilles et les hommes, il y a
les différences évolutives flagrantes,
celles qui séparent
les insectes des mammifères.
Il y a aussi beaucoup de fascination
qui a conduit l’homme à emmener l’abeille
aux 4 coins du monde depuis longtemps.
Au Moyen-Orient, récemment,
on a retrouvé des jarres d’argile
vieilles de 6 000 ans
et, à l’intérieur, du miel
encore consommable.
Six mille ans.
Le miel,
ce nectar des dieux qui ne se dégrade pas.
Il est cité à plusieurs
reprises dans le Coran.
Il y est dit des abeilles que,
de leur ventre, sort une liqueur diaprée
en laquelle se trouve
une guérison pour les hommes.
Certains types de miel, de nos jours,
sont utilisés en médecine conventionnelle
pour faciliter la cicatrisation humaine.
Les arômes, les odeurs,
la texture d’un miel
dépendent uniquement
des fleurs dont il est issu.
Alors la prochaine fois que vous
dégusterez un miel, s’il vous plaît,
imaginez que ce soit un tableau
et que chaque pixel de ce tableau
soit une petite goutte de nectar
et que sa teinte, sa coloration,
sa saturation, dépendent
d’une seule et unique fleur.
Plus la végétation sera complexe,
plus le tableau ressemblera
à une œuvre de maître,
à un feu d’artifice.
Le miel est une image de la végétation
qui compose un paysage.
Et, les yeux fermés,
c’est votre palais qui vous permet
d’observer et d’apprécier ce paysage,
votre palais qui vous permet de vous
projeter dans ce fouillis de végétation
qu’ont parcouru les abeilles.
Les abeilles voient ce paysage d’une
manière totalement différente de la nôtre.
Elles ne voient pas le rouge,
elles voient les ultraviolets
et la coloration du monde des fleurs
leur apparaît bien plus riche.
Regardez ces images
d’une simple fleur d’aubergine.
Avec une infime différence
dans nos capteurs optiques,
le monde change déjà.
Le travail d’apiculteur a évolué,
mais c’est une activité qui se perpétue,
peu importe la mécanisation.
C’est une activité solitaire, difficile,
qui n’a rien de romantique.
Il nous est souvent nécessaire
de faire un pas de côté
pour nous rappeler
que l’abeille est fascinante.
Sous ma combinaison, je me dois
d’apprendre comment fonctionne une colonie
pour espérer pouvoir
récolter le surplus de miel.
Je dois sentir, écouter, regarder,
toucher une colonie, pour la comprendre.
En étant attentif,
je peux entendre une jeune reine
prévenir de son émergence,
de sa propre naissance.
Oui, car elle émet de fines
stridulations caractéristiques.
Dans l’élevage,
nulle pause pour l’éleveur.
Les temps changent, les saisons
s’enchaînent et on court derrière.
Nous accompagnons des animaux,
nous ne dominons pas les abeilles.
Nous sommes plutôt
comme une extension, un outil,
comme un cordon
entre les abeilles et les hommes.
Et on partage le quotidien d’une espèce
qui évolue sur Terre
depuis 30 millions d’années.
Entre les abeilles et les hommes,
et finalement entre
toutes les espèces terrestres,
il y a cet espace, ce volume d’air,
ce fragment de vide dans lequel nous
pouvons imaginer le cosmos en son entier.
Percevoir et ressentir l'étendue de la
complexité du vivant donne le vertige.
Un vertige fascinant.
Merci.
(Applaudissements)